welcome back at the end of the last
video I left you with a bit of a
question we had a situation where we had
a 1 kilogram object see this is the 1
kilogram object which I have drawn
neater in this video is 1 kilogram and
where on earth and it is and I need to
mention that because gravity is
different from planet to planet but as I
mentioned it's I'm holding it let's say
I'm holding it 10 meters above the
ground so this distance or this height
is 10 meters 10 meters and we're
assuming the acceleration of gravity
you know acceleration of gravity which
we also write is just G is let's assume
it's just 10 meters per second squared
just for the simplicity of the mass of
the 9.8 so we learned in the last video
is that the potential energy in this
situation the potential energy which
equals M times G times H is equal to the
mass is one kilogram times the
acceleration of gravity just 10 meters
per second squared I'm not going to
write the unit's now to just to save
space all your you should do this when
you do it on your test and then the
height is 10 meters and the unit's if
you work them all out it's Newton meters
or joules and this equals so it's equal
to 100 joules that's the potential
energy when I'm holding it up there and
I asked you well when I let go what
happens well the block obviously will
start falling and not only falling it
will start accelerating to the ground at
10 meters per second squared roughly and
right before it hits the ground
let me draw that in brown for ground
right before the object hits the ground
or actually right when it hits the
ground what will be the potential energy
of the object well it has no height
right potential energy is mg H the mass
and the acceleration of gravity stay the
same but the height is zero so this
they're all multiplied by each other so
down here the potential energy is going
to be equal to zero and I told you in
the last video that we have the law of
conservation of energy that energy is
conserved it cannot be created or
destroyed it can just be converted from
one form to another but I'm just showing
you I had this object had a hundred
joules of energy in this case
gravitational potential
energy and down here it has no energy or
at least it has no gravitational
potential energy and that's the key that
gravitational potential energy was
converted into something else and that
something else that was converted into
is kinetic energy and in this case since
it has no potential energy all of that
previous potential energy all of this
hundred joules that it has up here all
of this hundred joules is now going to
be converted into kinetic energy and we
can use that information to figure out
its velocity right before it hits the
ground so how do we do that well what's
the formula for kinetic energy and we we
solved it two videos ago and hopefully
it shouldn't be too much of a mystery to
you it's something good to memorize but
it's also good to know how we got it and
go back to videos if if you forgot so
kinetic energy so first we know that all
the potential energy was converted into
kinetic energy we had 100 joules of
potential energy so we're still going to
have 100 joules but now all of its going
to be kinetic energy and kinetic energy
is one-half MV squared so we know that
one-half MV squared or the kinetic
energy is now going to equal 100 joules
but what's the mass the mass is 1 and we
can solve for V now one-half V squared
is equal hundred joules V squared is
equal to 200 and then we get V is equal
to square root of 200 which is something
over 14 we can get the exact number C
200 square root fourteen point one
roughly velocity is going to be fourteen
point one meters per second squared down
roots right before the object touches
the ground right before it touches the
ground and you might say well Sal that's
nice and everything that's you know we
learn a little bit about energy but what
you know I could have solved that or
hopefully you could have solved that
problem just using your Kino Mattox
formula so what's the whole point of
introducing these concepts of energy and
I will now show you so let's say they
have the same 1 kilogram object up here
and it's 10 meters in the air but I'm
going to change things a little bit I'm
going to change things a little bit so
let me let me see if I can competently
erase all of this
nope that's not what I wanted to do okay
there you go
trying my best to erase this all of this
stuff okay so I have the same object
it's still 10 meters in the air and I'll
write that in a second but it and I'm
still going to and I'm just holding
there I'm still going to drop it but
something interesting is going to happen
instead of it going straight down it's
actually going to drop on this ramp of
ice so it's good it's good that ice has
lumps on it it's kind of and then this
is the bottom this is the ground down
here this is the ground so what's going
to happen this time I'm still 10 meters
in the air so let me draw that that's
still 10 meters and I should switch
colors just so not everything is ice so
that's still 10 meters but instead of
the object going straight down now it's
going to go down here then start sliding
right it's going to go sliding along
this hill and then at this point it's
going to be going really fast
in the horizontal direction right now we
don't know how fast and just using our
Kino Mattox formula this would have been
a really tough formula this would have
been difficult I mean you would have had
to I mean you could have attempted it
actually you've taken calculus because
the angle of the slope changes
continuously we don't even know the
formula for the angle of the slope you
would have had to break it out into
vectors you would have to do all sorts
of complicated things this would have
been a nearly impossible problem but
using energy we can actually figure out
what the velocity of this object is at
this point and we use the same idea
here we have a hundred joules of
potential energy we just figure that out
down here what's the height above the
ground well the height is zero so all
the potential Energy's disappeared and
just like in the previous situation all
of the potential energy is now converted
into kinetic energy and so what is that
kinetic energy going to equal it's going
to be equal to the initial potential
energy so here the kinetic energy is
equal to Kut joules hundred joules and
that equals one-half MV squared just
like we just solved and if you solve for
V use you know the mass is one kilogram
so the velocity in the horizontal
direction will
be if you saw four it 14.1 meters per
second instead of going straight down
now it's going to be going in Indy in
the horizontal to the right and the
reason why I said it was Isis because I
wanted us to be frictionless and I
didn't want any lot energy loss to heat
or anything like that
anyway I'd say okay so that's kind of
interesting and you kind of got the same
number then when for the velocity than
if I just dropped the object straight
down and that's interesting but you know
what that's what what else can this do
for me and this is where it's really
cool not only can I figure out the the
velocity right when all of the potential
energies disappeared but I can figure
out the velocity at any point and this
is fascinating along this slide so let's
say when the box is sliding down here so
let's say the box is at this point so
slightly it changes colors to as it
falls so this is the one kilogram box
right Falls and it slides down here and
let's say at this point at this point
it's height above the ground is five
meters so what's its what's its
potential energy here so let's just
write something all the energy is
conserved right so the initial potential
energy plus the initial kinetic energy
is equal to the final potential energy
plus the final kinetic energy right I'm
just saying energy is conserved here up
here we what was the initial total
energy in the system well the potential
energy is 100 and the kinetic energy is
zero because it's it's stationary I
haven't dropped it yeah I haven't I'm
not even I haven't let go of it yet so
it's just stationary so the initial
energy is going to be equal to 100
joules that's because this is zero and
this is 100 so the initial energy is 100
joules at this point at this point what
right here what's the potential energy
well we're five meters up so mass times
gravity times height mass is 1 times
gravity 10 meters per second squared
times height times 5 so it's 50 joules
that's our potential energy at this
point and then we must have some kinetic
energy going roughly with the velocity
going roughly in that direction plus our
kinetic energy
at this point and we know that no energy
was destroyed
it's just converted so we know the total
energy still has to be 100 joules so
essentially what happened if we solve
for this is very easy subtract 50 from
both sides we know that the kinetic
energy is now also going to be equal to
50 joules so what happened halfway down
essentially half of the potential energy
got converted to kinetic energy and we
can use this information that the
kinetic energy is 50 joules to figure
out the velocity at this point one-half
MV squared is equal to 50 the mass is 1
multiply both sides by 2 you get V
squared is equal to 100 the velocity is
10 meters per second along this crazy
icy slide and that is something that I
would have challenged you to solve using
traditional kinematics formulas
especially considering that we don't
know really much about the surface of
this of this of this slide and even if
we did that would have been a million
times harder than just using it just
using the law of conservation of energy
and realizing that at this point half
the potential energy is now kinetic
energy and it's going along the
direction of slide I will see you in the
next video